Oi
[Música]
boa tarde a todos vamos falar de entenda
Cinzento a ética a ética sem
intermitências
épocas em implementar intermitências
porque é todos os tempos e em todo tempo
a pouco falava-se do tempo a ética é do
tempo do Cronos observe a expressão
grega cronômetro mas também é do tempo
do kairós do tempo espiritual a ética
sem intermitências também significa que
não se compadece com
conjunções adversativas não podemos ser
sobre a ética mas nestas circunstâncias
talvez salve-se mais ou menos que é uma
especial aliás muito portuguesa e na
boca
e uma advertência que eu aqui faço é que
ao falar estética não estou a falar de
moral
muita gente pensa que ética e moral são
sinônimos não é verdade para muito
resumidamente a moral é da minha esfera
privada intimista eu posso ter uma moral
Cristã é uma moral confecciona uma moral
asséptica uma moral tribal meu amor
alguns uma
mas não tenho o direito de
relacionar impondo esta moral todos os
outros a ética é diferente é que é
práxis na nossa vida através das nossas
atitudes nossos comportamentos
das dos costumes da relação com o outro
em que encontramos regras de baseadas
obviamente em princípios que devem ser
harmônicos do com o Nacional
Oi tudo bem
[Música]
e nesta bravíssima
abordagem das questões éticas Eu
gostaria de
falar deste cinco esquema comecemos por
mais básico da nossa condição de ser
humano
somos indivíduos que aliás são as
pessoas que se usa mais em mim atender
erradamente somos indivíduos e isto é
somos seres e repetíveis
somos um fragmento de uma espécie Mas
aquelas árvores Ou aquelas buganvílias
ali ao fundo a versão indivíduos um gato
uma mosca que passa aqui também é um
individo só seres vivos solicite fez o
teste é uma noção sobretudo biológica e
para aumentar os a exigência da nossa
qualificação como seres humanos devemos
passar a uma efeito iluminado uma série
delas obviamente a categoria do cidadão
cidadã da
a condição O que é o seu um cidadão é
ser portador de direitos e de obrigações
no ordenamento jurídico na lei na Norma
Jurídica é Portanto tem sobretudo na
dimensão social e
jurídica acontece que por exemplo Vamos
com o nosso cartão justamente de cidadão
O que é que nós temos lá temos o nosso
nome temos um dos nossos pais dois
elementos fundamentais para
nos darmos uns aos outros até alguns
dados
relativamente secundários e diziam
conhecem através do meu cartão cidadão
o criasse o que eu tenho de bom através
do meu cartão cidadão não teria se
aquilo que eu tenho de pior através do
meu cartão decisão não
porque a porque temos de subir a um
patamar que é um patamar de pessoa não é
preciso ser pessoa humana porque é um
eufemismo pessoa em que a dimensão É e
aqui sim é pika o que é que é ser pessoa
e se distingue dos animais ou da do
mundo Botânico é a termos vontade
percepção sensibilidade
espírito
aspectos que aliás de algumas
intervenções anteriores foram estão
implícitos na daquilo que foi dito e é
aqui que se está verdadeiramente a
dimensão ética por isso aliás nós não
podemos dizer que somos mais ou menos
pessoa mas podemos sempre dizer Somos
melhores ou piores pessoas do que ontem
ou em Rua Souza
E aí
de algum modo
a alma tendência que é também um Espero
que eu gostaria de chamar a atenção de
confundir as normas éticas com Conjunto
das normas jurídicas ou seja da Lei Isto
é o regime muito perigoso aliás nós
ouvimos frequentemente nas televisões
algumas pessoas dizerem mas eu fui
eticamente irrepreensível porque cumprir
escrupulosamente a lei isso pode ser uma
falácia os seus por exemplo eram
zeladores e cumpridores cor populosos da
Lei e no entanto a palavra chegou a hoje
nós com o significado de temos é um
fariseu tem um comportamento farisaico o
que é que isto quer dizer evidentemente
que a lei
justa tem uma grande componente ética
mas aspectos da lei que não tem qualquer
vertente ou consideração ética sei lá
consigo a direita ou pela esquerda é um
bom então aqui é pra direita no Reino
Unido é para a esquerda
mas e sobretudo o aspecto eu gostaria
aqui referi mais são as normas éticas
que ainda não foram vertidos para a lei
ordinária
e algumas delas nunca poderão ser
o porquê que distingue o Norma Jurídica
é ser legal ser ilegal o que distingue a
Norberto que é ser legítimo ou seremos
gitmo há nenhuma lei pode ser
a ser cover consagrados princípios sobre
que me obriguem a ser solidário a ser
amigo a ser leal a ser autêntico a ser
verdadeiro
é melhor que sejam bem
assim como ao contrário não há nenhuma
Lake na sua totalidade por vivamente
vida por viva a ganância pro Iva o ódio
Expresso R7 a ou se achegar parte do
nosso comportamento
e num tem que ter em conta o respeito à
lei jurídica pela lei positiva mas
fundamental para o melhor ou para o pior
nós próprios não está na Live está no
domínio ético eu objeção de consciência
vou passar para não perder muito tempo
e a eu gostaria de
dizer o seguinte a várias formas de
ferir ética é aquela é uma expressão da
filosofia moral
não é uma ao segura não é o algoritmo
não é uma ciência
eu cito apenas para não passar muito a
definição que apesar de tudo Acho que é
mais curta e mais
adequada de ética é a expressão da forma
como nos relacionamos com os outros foi
a definição muito simples desse grande
artista que Aliás o meu favorito que é
cante o Emanuel não o alentejano i Oi
e eu entendo que a ética e chama
definição muito pessoal muito minha até
com classe como economista é a soma de
um conjunto de valores e de um conjunto
de saberes
de quanto tá os valores estão aqui
alguns deles é tipo de exemplo na Lisboa
referencial são são explicados por se
aliás eu aqui embaixo pergunto qual
desses valores a quais desses valores
estão invertidos na lei quase nenhum um
animal awake-ish
sobre a prudência sobre a autenticidade
de sobre a exatidão sobre a coerência de
apenas uma pequena referência a a
direito versos de ver eu não pus Eu
juntei uns através de um Infame porque
eu no fundo quer dizer que o verdadeiro
valor ético é o valor do direito de
dizer são irmãos siameses estão
condenados entre "a viver juntos não há
direitos sem deveres e não há deveres
sem direitos e quando se fragmenta esta
unidade ontológica alguma coisa vai
correr mal dentro de nós as nossas
famílias nossas casas nas nossas
atividades e no planeta e da pouco se
falava de direitos e deveres e
é
[Música]
fundamentalmente ambiental e quantas
saberes
é
apenas simplificadamente temos aqui
muitos saberes Eu apenas e sempre fico
desta maneira para dizer que o
importante na ética não é o não são os
saberes é sabedoria que resulta do
compósito da soma da harmonia de tantos
saberes que é que estão referidos
como saber cognitivo que é o que se
aprende no conhecimento o saber a
entender que a compreensão é bem estão
todos eles e nós sabemos aliás que as
pessoas que são ótimas fontes de saber
cognitivo E no entanto falham porque não
sabem liderar ou porque não sabem
decidir ou porque não sabem aprender com
a experiência e com apesar de hoje Ética
do erro
bom
e como nós não podemos dispensar nenhum
destes saberes que na nossa ação só duas
ou três voltas muito rápidas
isto também fala por sim uma é
para distinguir o conhecimento EA
compreensão que é o saber se ver e saber
entender
eu vou mostrar o exemplo vamos supor que
eu não sei
porque a sair gosto muito mas nunca
provei o sabor da canela não sei o que é
o sabor da canela e vamos porque ele
desta audiência estava prontos maiores
especialistas na canela e todos os
queriam manuais competentíssimos com
referências e investigações científicas
sobre o sabor da canela eu ia ler todos
os manuais e chegava ao fim e não
conseguia saber qual era o verdadeiro
sabor da canela ou seja muito da nossa
saber muito da nossa sabedoria resulta
de viver e não para o a seguir por dia
será vertical criativa está o amor está
assim velocidade está a solidariedade
estão as maiores pressões das nossas
vidas resulta justamente
desta história e resultam também da
história da do jovem com a jiboia jiboia
não é que De algum modo é que se disser
para se aprender afinal de contas as
grandes as máquinas questões que nós
temos a gente sofre também
saber envolver se eu estou a fazer isto
que uma vez um volume perguntou-me mas
saber vou ver se é igual a servir
comprometer-se por isso não alto
envolvimento é uma coisa comprometimento
é outra coisa e da altura lembrei-me de
um manual que eu já li a 30 30 e 40 anos
a
digestão hummm hummm hummm
americano é que este guia dava uma um
exemplo o desenvolvimento
comprometimento ele dizia Suponha que
está comer em casa ou no restaurante um
ovo estrelado e presunto
e ele dizia está a ver
e a galinha está envolvida mas o porco
está comprometido
e continuando a
ele a fim de tantas teorias éticas que
apenas volto atacante porque Kant tem
essa aspecto notável de definir o dever
através daquele chamou o imperativo
categórico também não sou uma são muito
bonito mas defunto
consubstanciado uma ética da
reciprocidade não faças aos outros o que
não queres que te façam a ti e faz aos
outros o que desejas que te façam quando
for em relação a ti
este facto é um teste automático entre
aspas
do exercício ético ou seja nós não
mentimos ou não devemos mentir porque se
for ao contrário não queremos que nos
mim tão é relação a nós nós não queremos
ser desleais porque não queremos que
outro outro seja desleal em relação a
nós e cante
tratou esticou uma notável sabedoria eu
ali eu ia o dever ativo do dever passivo
ele dizia que o dizer passe que é
obrigação do obrigado não tenho grande
quer ser respeitado mas não é aqui que
está a essência da ética Ou seja eu sou
obrigado a pagar impostos tem que pagar
pessoa obrigação de obrigada um ver
passivo e se for a renda tem que pagar a
renda eles tiveram um empréstimo
hipotecário tem que pagar a mensalidade
ao banco sabe
bastante dizia atenção o importante é o
dizer ativos é aquele em que eu não sou
obrigado planta obrigação mas aquele que
eu me alta obrigo
e em que o meu tribunal interior me leva
aqui por ser desta maneira
sou encontrará uma pessoa daquele lado
da rua que entendo olhando para ela que
está está mal disposta e precisa de
algum socorre e ajuda ele tem que
conseguir um brigar eu não sou obrigado
tinha uma Vai por mim um contrato ajudar
essa pessoa e esta noção da obrigação do
obrigante é que eu me constituo como
Obrigado que é notável nesta definição
de Campo deixa vale a ser uma vez disso
aos meus alunos o seguinte
da festa de uma sequência desses vocês
não amanhã não vem fazer aqui a
frequência eu vou usar o enunciado
envelope fechado
vocês vão para casa mede as duas horas
que é quando demora a frequência não
consulta um livro não falam com ninguém
depois fecham e trazem para correção e
classificação por e eu perguntei qual
vocês é capaz de fazer isto sem batota e
Heroes todos porque a Pois é isso daqui
é que isso aqui é a tica Por que a ética
não é porque aquela pessoa me está a ver
ouvir Como está a fiscalizar ou porque
está na lei
reside em nós e o tribunal interior que
temos
consciência é sem dúvida a grande
Vitória Épica que temos à nossa
disposição vou terminar
dizendo apenas que se eu tivesse que
definir peço desculpa de algum
pessimismo também já tenho idade para
ser feita em vista não é
se eu tivesse que atualizar as
sociedades contemporâneas dias se a
questão sobretudo submetidas ao
subjetivismo e relativismo Ou seja hoje
a tendência para transformar alguns
valores e princípios que eram
indiscutíveis não espécie de pedra pomes
em que fala é mais as opiniões do que os
valores e os princípios e o
individualismo Ou seja a ditadura do em
primeiro lugar e o sucesso sobre consumo
tudo isto junto a indiferença ao
indiferentismo que de facto a uma como a
um uma perspectiva muitas vezes passiva
e acomodatícia gera aspectos
preocupantes de vista ético e a rir aqui
Embora tenha atua neste meio tempo ao
tempo mas podia só mais um minuto
para falar daqui outros americanos
chamam a moral me disse a mude as moral
que é a linguagem que se usa hoje em dia
não é a linguagem que seja hoje em dia
aqui daqui Alguns chamam linguagem
politicamente correta a é uma linguagem
que procura retirar
a proteção moral e ética de algumas
questões e por isso constantemente
estamos em inventar palavras para
desgraçar moralmente o que elas essas
palavras representam hoje uma frase um
dúvida tecnocrática mente a imparidade
uma o conflito de interesses a quem
chama de sinergia um
copiar passa a ser copiado passe
a interrupção o aborto passou a ser um
acrónimo e VG entre educação com carga
de sol e ver aliás aqui com o aspecto
até por esse sim é que se
verdadeiramente não se trata de
interromper a gravidez Mas dia fazer
cessar só coisas diferentes a eutanásia
morte clinicamente assistida quase com
harpa não é uma pouquinho está aqui
vamos ver o
as placas são grupos organizados de
adeptos o despedimento é ilegal diz
assim fica bem dizer
[Música]
a mentira a mentira é uma inverdade
não podíamos estar aqui e sempre se toda
alguns economistas tem muito quando a
situação da economia fala em crescimento
zero que ela essa moça eu disse uma
piscina de zero pai
qualquer dia o sei lá ainda vou ver nas
perto de viver para ver o anão a ser o
cidadão verticalmente favorecido
ou um furto ter redução de patrimônio
por ver ai a FCT 7 nós vamos lá chegar é
uma questão de tempo mas de facto isto
retira 91 tomar mais
[Música]
muito do ponto de vista ético as
expressões não será por acaso agora
a vou terminar com estas cinco aspectos
que eu considero para mim pelo menos
essenciais a prioridade da ética sobre a
técnica não que a técnica não seja
importante ela está ser decisiva mas não
transferência Épica no fim mas apenas no
meio ou instrumento para alcançar
o primado das pessoas sobre as coisas
e às vezes nós chegamos ao fim do dia as
macaco as coisas
esquecendo das pessoas
a conjugação entre verbos ser e verbo
ter
como expressões da nossa da nossa
felicidade a valorização dos fios sobre
os meios e o exercício dos deveres com
harmônico aferição dos direitos F foi a
estou quis dizer em 15 minutos é muito
difícil falar de ética em 15 minutos era
para mim muito mais fácil falar em 5
horas
mas
apenas para dizer e termino que
Citando de confuso a 2.500 anos ele já
dizia imagina não procuro tanto saber as
respostas mas sobretudo compreender as
perguntas e hoje nós temos quase todas
as vezes andamos à procura das perguntas
para essas mesmas respostas Muito
obrigado
[Música]